القتال في شوارع السودان هو
وقف إطلاق النار بلا هوادة بعد أن لم يصمد وقف إطلاق النار
للقوات المتهمة سابقًا بارتكاب إبادة جماعية،
وعودة إلى قواعد اللعبة البالية،
وترويع، وطرد
قوات الدعم السريع شبه العسكرية وتطهيرها عرقيًا، وتشارك قوات الدعم السريع شبه العسكرية
حاليًا في قتال من أجل
الهيمنة مع الجيش السوداني.  ولكن
قبل سنوات من إراقة الدماء في
شوارع السودان، تورطوا في
فظائع في تلك القلعة التي تقع الآن مرة أخرى في مدينة
دارتفورد غرب البلاد،
ويطاردها شبح الإبادة الجماعية،
والضرر الذي أحدثته هذه القوات
واسع النطاق لدرجة أنه يمكنك رؤيته من صور الأقمار الصناعية.
قُتل المئات من مناطق بأكملها مرفوعة
على الأرض،
وليست جينينا فقط هي التي
تحترق، بل هي
أندور
وهذا كادومي
على الأرض، تبدو هذه
المشاهد مألوفة للأسف، حيث
انحدرت المنطقة منذ 20 عامًا إلى
إبادة جماعية
نفس قيادة قوات الدعم السريع في  مكان حيث
يقتل رجالهم ويغتصبون
الآن مرة أخرى، أصبحت أجساد النساء جزءًا
من مجال الحرب.
هذا الفيديو مزعج للغاية بحيث لا يمكن
بثه بالكامل ولكنه يستمر في إظهار
فتاة يُعتقد أنها تبلغ من العمر 15 عامًا فقط
تتعرض للاغتصاب، كما ترى هنا  رجل يرتدي
زيًا فاتح اللون يتطابق مع تلك التي
ترتديها قوات الدعم السريع، لقد أوقفنا الفيديو مؤقتًا
قبل أن تتحرك الكاميرا لإظهار
جندي آخر يرتدي نفس الزي الرسمي،
ويجبر نفسه على الفتاة المنبطحة على الأرض،
وتتحقق شبكة CNN من المنطقة
التي حدث فيها هذا وتحدد موقعها الجغرافي.  الكشف عن
الموقع الدقيق لحماية
مصادرنا والفتاة،
هذه ليست حادثة معزولة،
تلقينا واستعرضنا عشرات الحالات
حيث تقول النساء إنهن تعرضن للاغتصاب من قبل جنود الدعم السريع، حيث
تعرفوا عليهن من خلال ملابسهن ذات الألوان الفاتحة
والشارات الموجودة على
أكتافهم اليمنى.  إذن، من هو المتواطئ في هذا
الألم،
الحليف الرئيسي لقوات
مراسلون بلا حدود، مجموعة فاغنر الروسية سيئة السمعة، التي
تواصل قتالها وتوفر
الدافع لذبح الأبرياء من خلال
توفير الأسلحة، سنوضح لك
كيف أن
هذه طائرة شحن وهمية 76
تديرها  فاغنر يجلس في
قاعدة جوية ليبية كشف تحقيق سابق لشبكة CNN
كيف كانت طائرة الشحن الروسية هذه
تزود قوات الدعم السريع بأسلحة فتاكة من
قاعدة بحرية روسية في اللاذقية بسوريا
عبر القواعد التي تسيطر عليها فاغنر في ليبيا.
هذا الشخص يبدأ قبل أيام فقط من
بدء الحرب في السودان.
ليبيا سوريا وضفتها وتتسارع
وتيرة الأمر المثير للاهتمام
هنا هو التركيز الجديد
على المدينة حيث يتجه بعد ذلك بونجي
عاصمة جمهورية أفريقيا الوسطى
بعد تعرضنا لطريق ليبيا وهو
طريق مباشر من جمهورية أفريقيا الوسطى
إلى ذلك الحصن الذي أصبح
وقال شهود عيان من قوات الدعم السريع في نقاط العبور الرئيسية والمخابرات النشطة في المنطقة لشبكة
CNN إن الأسلحة والإمدادات من هذا الحل
تم نقلها براً باستخدام الشاحنة التي
تم الاستيلاء عليها هنا وغيرها مثلها
أولاً إلى قاعدة فاغنر في البيرو ثم
إلى جنوب دارتفورد إلى قاعدة قوات الدعم السريع.  في
undaf،
تضع فاغنر إبهامها على الميزان
هنا لتأمين الوصول إلى
موارد السودان عبر دارفور، مما يخلق الفوضى
والإرهاب، مما يساعد على قلب ميزان
القوى في حربهم في أوكرانيا مهما كانت
التكلفة.